back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome welcome back
sorry about the technical difficulties
there
mute was on some different things are
going on i think we have the
correspondent back from really news now
we'll find out what's going on with that
let's see if we can let's see if we can
make this work now
and correspondent can you now hear me
yes uh we can hear you sorry it looked
like there were some sexual deviants out
uh in the streets causing some issues
with uh our connection so i apologize to
my fellow american patriots how are you
all that that happens sometimes with all
the sexual anarchy going around so you
gave us a report there about the sexual
anarchy from the super bowl um were you
were you present at the super bowl while
all the sexual anarchy was going on
no you would you would not catch me
anywhere near that super bowl
um i i caught some clips online i
watched from the um
the safety of my own home yeah um but
let me tell you now that
uh
i wouldn't go anywhere near the super
bowl
why why wouldn't you go near the super
bowl
why would i not yeah what what what
about this super bowl makes it to where
you did not want is it this just a super
bowl or is it all of them it was just
the super bowl okay what what
specifically was it because it was in in
california or los angeles
or was it because who was playing what's
what's the reason why you wouldn't uh
take an assignment to report
is there something you know i was told
the musical artist was going to be
eminem yeah
um
and i later found out that it was not
actually
the m ms
it was eminem oh so so the the the
disappointment about the sexual anarchy
is that it wasn't candy sexual anarchy
it's that it was
um maybe human
sexual anarchy is that is that what i'm
hearing exactly okay so slim shady
disappointed you when you seen that it
was the rapper eminem not the green
eminem
sexy boots
yes and also uh miss brown eminem
um yes a librarian well you know
you you have to give you you seem like
you get excited when you talk about the
um the librarian brown eminem i mean
would you not also um
well you know what it seems it seems
kind of weird that that that people of
your ilk
um find find that m ms should be sexy
but people at the super bowl dancing for
entertainment should not be sexy it
really is kind of backwards to me i i
don't see any way that would be
backwards uh i find that to be
completely linear in logical thought so
you think that candy should be sexy
but people should not be who are dancing
i think candy i think cartoons uh lola
bunny
right um
[Music]
you know
i don't see an issue with um
these
entities uh having um
a a as you put it as sexualized or uh
you know an appearance
that is in that way um i think that's
totally fine and i think that you know
if you do
and you know i i you know i i feel like
you're gonna come at me with this you
just talked about how we shouldn't
sexualize things and how it's
un-american but i would tell you right
now if you look in uh the bible you know
st john's bible and you look in there in
leviticus 14 sections one through three
um you would see that even christ
himself said um
look unto thou candy for it is
sexual
it says it says that in in where
leviticus is that what you said yes it
talks about candy uh-huh and also uh in
luke mark uh and john
also there is a different book as well
different um
interpretations
of
uh how jesus
spread
his
his
sweet his sweet
semen sermon semen what did you say
uh
i i believe
i believe i said sweet sermon oh okay i
don't know where you are i misheard you
i'm very sorry i misheard you i would
never those words would never cross my
mouth unless i were
giving some sort of
um biological uh course i know i know
that i know that um you know um jesus
turns most um evangelical christians so
do you identify as a as a evangelical
white fragile male excuse me a white
male is it evangelical
whitening is it strong as a strong male
i i do identify
weak weak is that what you said i i said
strong oh strong okay because i see what
you're trying to do here tony you know
is this some sort of like hit job you're
trying to attack me right now is this
the is no no i'm just i'm just trying to
i'm just trying to i'm trying i'm trying
to get to the truth here
i delivered the truth you know and that
truth is true from god speaking through
me to give you the the the information
that you need to know about
the sexual anarchy in this country and
how we have devolved into a nation that
purely lives off of these sexual
temptations and desires have you ever
been to an nfl football game have you
ever been to one
i have okay
have you uh have you watched some
halftime shows during an nfl football
game like just any not just this super
bowl but any of them in general have you
ever seen
those super bowl or the the just the
regular one is that the super bowl i
don't think that is an important uh
question or thing to answer i i was just
wondering if you'd ever seen some of the
cheerleading squads i mean they're
beautiful most of them they're they're
very very beautiful women have you seen
the cheerleading response for some of
the like the dallas cowboys possibly i
don't know what cheerleaders are
you don't have any idea what
cheerleaders are no honestly so you were
this is the first time that i'm hearing
the word
cheerleader oh okay so this is the very
first time but you definitely know
what the green and brown sexy eminem
candy is apparently
yes okay well speaking of eminem's and
eminem the rap artist how did you feel
about eminem taking
a knee during his performance after he
um
did his musical number there un-american
was an american that was american
that was a complete
insult
to the flag
okay so so it wasn't during the national
anthem so i'm very confused why it's an
insult to the flag if it wasn't during
the national anthem because the flag
holds true over all of us at all times
it's like god
it sits there
heavenly father our heavenly flag sits
above us all 13 stripes and 50 stars red
white and blue
so this this also goes back to if you've
ever watched the football game you know
tim i know you know tim tebow you know
tim t he's he's a man of god right a
true man of god yeah yeah he he prays
during games when he scores you know he
does and you know what he does when he
does it he kneels on the field he kneels
are you against tim tebow kneeling
in the name of god oh okay so so in that
case when the flag's flying and the flag
is always flying in that case not so
offensive but when eminem takes a knee
after his musical performance
definitely offensive and then america is
offensive it is an insult it is like uh
throwing dirt in the eyes of america do
you have do you have any idea why he
would kneel during that point during his
performance i mean i think i know why
but you know why
you know his
his you know so it's un-american to be
to be a little exhausted after a
performance is that what you're saying
listen i heard some lyrics from his song
about spaghetti and the sweater and his
knees were heavy so i you know it would
make sense why he might take anything it
seemed like he was a little weak and
exhausted
i think i think the reason why he was
taking the knee is to give solidary for
for black people being killed by police
i don't know if you know colin
kaepernick is you know do you does that
name sound familiar to you colin
kaepernick a traitor
oh you think colin kaepernick is a
traitor
oh okay so so colin kaepernick kneeling
in solidarity for um black people being
killed by police is is is trade treason
as traitorous right i mean that it i'm
i'm just uh repeating the words of trump
you know oh so so trump is is uh the the
word of god on this is what you're
saying yeah yeah okay so so let me ask
you what about the trump supporters who
went to the capitol and and were
carrying american flags and a lot of
times blue lives matter flags and we're
beating and killed a police officer
do you think that's offensive do you
think that's unpatriotic do you think
that's un-american do you think that's
probably a lot more significant
in our you know timeline that we have
here to
call someone a traitor i think they were
trying to overthrow the constitution in
the united states overthrow i think is a
little liberal of a word there tony i
think you're exaggerating so what would
the word be if it's not overthrow um it
looked uh from my account and also some
insider reports from fbi agents that
this was an inside job
it's an inside job of all of those
people were just actors
the the people who are the 750 political
prisoners that the republicans are
trying to get released are actors i
haven't seen any paperwork i've only
seen a number that uh
mayor garland has said so no your guys
is your guys's mouth and [ __ ] really
do collide here when you talk out your
ass and your mouth because here's the
thing because you you always say two
different things i want sexy eminem with
boots but when mary j blige goes on the
super bowl and wears the sexy boots
that's sexual anarchy i want i want
people
i love when people go to the capitol and
use american flags to beat and kill
police officers but eminem
eminem cannot cannot kneel
during a halftime show in solidarity
with black people being killed by police
officer with per uh
with police brutality
you see how these things are kind of
opposite right do you no
i don't i'm just going to tell you how
it is tony here at rnn we really do
report on the news that is happening the
important facts of the matter you know
this isn't some uh we're gonna cancel
you we're gonna we're gonna get rid of
you we're gonna say that oh you said
this or did that you know no no no we
are unfiltered true
americans at heart so you definitely
don't want cancer cultures what you're
saying
nope nope no no no one should be
canceled is what you're saying no no
cancel culture no no i want to cancel
cancel culture okay i want to cancel
cancel gold so let me ask you with the
super bowl should because of what
happened with what you say is and you uh
ben shapiro charlie kirk is calling this
sexual deviance the sexual anarchy as
you as you say it
do you think
do you think that they should be
canceled for doing that on on live
television during the halftime show do
you think they should be canceled oh
they should not be able to get a job
ever again oh okay should not be able to
hold a concert venue or perform for
anyone ever again i mean
that's the struggle of the american
trust and the people
are you kidding me this is
an utter disgrace of just
uh uh just an insult like i said i mean
you know we paid these people to perform
at the show
and instead of just
doing what the nfl said you know we're
taking knees and we're shaking booties
and we're smoking joints
this is not what america was built on
this is not the america that we want to
have today right so just now just now in
this in this timeline right now
just figured out that snoop dogg smokes
weed so you want to cancel him but you
are going to cancel cancer culture is
what you're saying you see how these two
things do not do not add up
nope
you're not sure
i i see them as completely separate
things
i would say that
actions and these are consequences like
you guys like to say consequence culture
you know some people say it's not
cancelled culture it's consequence
culture but let me tell you
they made those choices and these are
the consequences that come from them so
so let me ask you one more thing because
a lot of people are are saying that the
reason why the right wing um i don't
know if you consider yourself right wing
or not or or maga right wing as in
correct wing if that's what you mean
oh correct okay well fine um we'll play
we'll play ball there so you right
wingers out there um are
it seems like it seems like the only
reason why they were upset about the
halftime show
is because the people performing were
black there was a lot of talk that there
was only one white person which was
eminem but all the other performers were
black they seem like they have a problem
with that is that a problem that you
have
you know i i don't feel like i should
comment on this um
this is one of those things that i've
already made very clear you know okay i
think i said you know they shouldn't
have been shaking their butts they
shouldn't have been taking knees they
should have been smoking joints these
are the things that we lead to a
a a a state of society we're going to
have a state of emergency is what's
going to happen you know we're going to
need someone to come in and correct the
ways so that we can get back to our true
american christian
path you mean like totalitarianism is
that what you're saying like authorities
i'm just saying whatever it takes to get
us
forward on that path oh okay so even if
we got to shut down the economy to do
that because i heard in l.a i don't know
we need to shut it down tony i'm just
telling you right now i you know i
support those truckers up by canada you
know they are holding themselves true to
their faith and their ideology
what what what is their ideology exactly
with the canadian trucker
a tyrannical government and and society
cannot tell them what they can and
cannot do with their body so this is
their moment to stand up and revolt or
or park and revolt does it work
sure because they're blocking they're
blocking commerce and they're they're
trying from my understanding sounds like
there's a supply chain issue right now
and it sounds like they if they were
given the right kind of
acknowledgement and freedom yeah they
would be able to be the heroes and they
would be able to fix this problem so the
supply chain seems to the supply chain
is is a is a funny thing because see
this is where the two sides of the coin
you guys straight on the [ __ ] fence
on this thing because so you had that
here in america i don't know you're here
in america but you're talking about
canada but here in america
we've been hearing the right wing [ __ ]
for the first year about supply chains
even the former guy your orange
mussolini jesus said supply change like
he wanted to change the supplies um i
don't know if that's referring to as
depends the supplies of diapers but you
know we won't go there that's but they
talk about the supply chains and now
what you they got to open up the supply
chains get them open they're open now
they want them close you see how this
again you're you're doing two things
that don't sound the same
no
not at all
just because for two years we had we had
the right wing screaming about opening
the economy and now they're talking
about shutting the economy down right we
need to open the economy that is correct
and the only way to open the economy is
to let those truckers do what they do
best truck
okay so so what why why then would
shutting the highways down and stopping
all the trucks why would that open the
economy
how would that open the economy it's
pretty simple okay it's pretty simple
really complicated but go ahead it's
pretty information right there is a
blockage right now and that blockage are
vaccines okay okay
and vaccines you know people want to say
oh you know my body my choice you know
don't put that in my body
that is your right
now think of think of this blockage
right this vaccine this meant this
ideology issue here that's causing the
problem now if we were able to get rid
of vaccines we just wipe away vaccines
altogether imagine the flow
that would come through
to help
improve supply chain okay how how does
how does 90 of canadian truckers being
vaccinated anything to do with the
blockage of vaccine you know that 90
percent of truckers are vexed do you
know why they don't have mandates
in
where you're talking about because they
don't need them because 90 of people are
already vacant they don't need mandates
you know that right you know i don't
know how they do things in canada but
clearly that's not america clearly you
don't clearly you don't know how to do
things in canada it seems like it seems
like you're confused did you see the
gofundme um and then they had another
gofundme type page get shut down for
their funding because it was a bunch of
fascist right-wing fascists raising
money to overthrow a government did you
see did you see they shut down the
gofundme and refunded all the money and
then shut down another fund me type
i did it was go fund me and gifts and go
i believe yeah gibson go yeah yeah
frozen honestly it's tyrannical coming
in and saying that you can't donate to
who you want to donate you know i i
believe that's uh that's a little bit
too far of a reach so when a private
platform a private fundraising platform
says you've broken their terms of
service
it's tyrannical is that what you're
saying that private companies i'm just
saying uh it's not fair
oh yeah so so not fair
equals tyrannical
in my book it does tony you know if you
don't get things how you want them to be
it seems unfair and that is not that is
not the true way of life that is that is
a christian wouldn't do that an american
wouldn't do that you know these are
things that i feel like are again too
far reaching for the government we need
to smaller government less control let
those things happen on their own you
know so why are you fully why why why
the right wing then is forcing uh school
boards not not to
have their own
policies on mask and vaccines then why
if if you don't want big government why
is big government stopping
school boards small government why are
they stopping them from having their own
policies you have like in several states
florida missouri texas um there's
attorney generals in those states suing
suing those school boards those small
governments as you call them big
government big state governments suing
them to prevent them from having
policies that they want
those those aren't those aren't small
governments those
what are they if they're not small
governments they're just a pot of people
oh so so it's more of the liberal woke
mob that are running schools exactly
yeah and and the actual small
governments are the state-run
governments the ones that you know you
know got those rs behind them you know
we got desantis so what you're saying is
democratic state governments are
are not good republican state
governments good
democratic state governments are going
to be the demise of the american society
you know much like sexual anarchy i
don't know how many ways i need to put
it here but i'm just letting you know
that that that type of uh
freedom or liberal agenda that you put
out there is actually going to be
something that brings us down as society
let me tell you our viewers
have to be super excited that you showed
up today to give us this report on the
super bowl halftime show and also to
give us your views
on uh sexual anarchy um i mean listen
again i'm don't shoot the messenger here
i'm just the person that is delivering
the news as to how it really is right
now right like really news now right
this is this is the thing that you're
going to do well well well carly cherk i
appreciate you uh that's your your name
right carly harley cirque carly cirque
i'm i apologize i apologize i i just
want to make sure i just i just hope
that uh you know if i come back on the
show later that you'll get the name
right you know i just think it's only
it's only fair that you are able to um
give me back that same respect that i
have toward you you know well i i wanna
i wanna say um i hope i hope you have a
happy valentine's day i really do and i
hope that you participate in all the
the um
the the sexual anarchy that you possibly
can with you and whoever you're you're
valentine
i will not be performing sexual anarchy
we really we really want to make sure
that on this valentine's day that we
have national
sexual anarchy no
no
i do not support that liberal agenda
you're pushing right now
the woke the woke mob out there
definitely definitely wants to have
enough sexual anarchy to go around you
know what this interview's over this
interview's over i'm done i'm done we're
done you know what i'm gonna say sexual
anarchy needs to go down
all right well he obviously got a little
pissed off there so stay stay tuned stay
right here we'll be right back
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]